hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast please make sure you
subscribe that way you get the episodes
as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage sure is it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find that they're great
to be classy or just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host
i'm your host h foley you sure
come out
[Laughter]
on a strokey day we're down here in
auntie's basement she's outside raking
leaves oh yeah it's fall court appointed
she's at the neighbors my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me he
is the ceo of ru garbage he's
international businessman cooks the
books keeps the feds off our back and
the rain off our heads give it up for kj
kevin james ryan hey gang happy to be
here thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate view subscribe
on itunes full video available on
youtube and as you know those numbers
are true to real [ __ ] cooking
um and then what was that
[ __ ] we've oh
what hold on
no patreon.com backslash all you garbage
greatest website of all time
shout out sign up get your bonus content
we're closing in on 20 000. no big deal
couple of bucks get me to france baby
let's go i'm flying yam airlines over
there let's do it and how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good fantastic stand-up
comedian pride of the chicago comedy
scene cut some tight videos down there
in houston that everybody loves give it
up for tebow mcmuffin toby
mcmullen what up dudes what's up t-bone
nothing got a lot of dms i didn't know
you could do that it's like where you
been what are you watching what the
videos yeah
that's for patreon gang we could not be
more excited to have our incredibly
special guest here with us today for the
first time uh we got history old pal old
pal from the [ __ ] from the village
scene back in the day all of us climbing
our way out of there baby he's doing big
things he's a very funny stand-up
comedian podcaster and actor and he is
the co-host of the amazing stiff socks
podcast with our good pal mr trevor
wallace the big question about his mind
today is he garbage he's a good-looking
kid but i can see it in his eyes i feel
like a guidance counselor yeah no good i
can tell give it up for michael blastine
everybody oh
man i'm [ __ ] happy to be here man i
always thought it was bloustein been
friends with you for literally about 10
years yeah you just corrected us today i
don't correct anybody that's good i like
that you know those people that like
that the starbucks people are like uh
samantha and the woman comes actually
samantha yeah [ __ ] you yeah
will you send [ __ ] back at a restaurant
or just leave it be um it's gotta be
really [ __ ] up right there
if i ordered like steak and it it it
came chicken that's when i'm like i
didn't order this
but it's gotta be you know i mean it's
gonna be really bad it's gonna be
horrendous sure
i've only done it once or twice man i
feel like comics because we have to work
so many shitty jobs a lot bars
restaurants yeah that no comic has
really the confidence or the ability to
send something back you know yeah cuz i
just know the whole rigamarole that goes
through the kitchen and the waiter and
then all the [ __ ] they gotta deal with
behind the scenes the chefs yelling you
put it in wrong no i don't
all that [ __ ] so it's like at this point
i'll i'll have the rigatoni
i order the duck but i'll take it yeah
i'll take it that's not bad then you're
trying something new i like it too
those kitchen politics or anybody who
worked in a restaurant it is
stiff negotiation does this guy like you
does that guy like you sometimes the
[ __ ] grill guy just hates your guts
for whatever and then all of a sudden he
forgets to make your [ __ ] and you look
like an [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah very nice what is
the origin story mr blastein where did
you grow up give us the full details i
grew up in uh silver spring maryland
okay yeah i thought you were jersey ah
my hair says jersey yeah silver spring
says the simpsons yeah my dick says
jewish
small dick joke off top guys hey you'll
fit in you'll fit in great here hey
everyone circumcised yeah yeah okay
what's up
little monster man yeah i got that
extended director's cut dogs
toby on blu-ray i like
i don't even like to think about it i do
i do this guy's hot i don't i don't
think about it i don't like it
silver springs yeah what kind of town
are we talking about near baltimore
where are we it's about 35 minutes
outside of baltimore about 15 minutes
outside of dc i feel like everybody says
that whenever they when whenever they're
from maryland about 35 minutes outside
baltimore yeah i mean i literally just
tell people in
because it's actually because it's the
follow-up question it's like when people
ask what you do and you're uh you don't
want to say comic because there's a
million other questions sure why did you
come up with your bids
that kind of [ __ ] i hate it um obviously
we all hit it but yeah i just say dc
normally but baltimore yeah we listen we
love you but yeah come on between
baltimore and dc i'm going with the
politics oh what a lobbyist a lot of
money
fish
hookers love them love them well who
doesn't like a nice hooker you know
[Laughter]
liquidation the [ __ ]
um
nice town
um yeah suburban life so bourbon
lifestyle uh had a cul-de-sac oh i was
also a cul-de-sac kid
when you say you had a cul-de-sac your
house was in the cul-de-sac or there was
a cul-de-sac in your neighborhood there
was a cul-de-sac at the end of my street
i wasn't a cold
because there was a basketball court
they had a basketball court right there
and no cars going on yeah and they were
that those like three or four houses
were always more unified than the rest
of the neighborhood they were a
tight-knit group it was a tight-knit
group because they knew they had it
really good yeah
[ __ ] we'd get together on friday
nights and laughing
regular street bozos that's what he
would do
no [ __ ] were you friends with the kids
in the cul-de-sac though they'll get
down there to shoot hoops every once in
a while that's the thing
here's the thing they treat you like a
caddy you get one day you're a
second-class citizen if you're on there
if you're on the avenue it's not a good
look the rest of the neighborhood gets
one day a year to use the basketball
courts have a little cookout for you
dude i worked at a country club and they
own they didn't let they let women on
the country club one day a year really
oh no i'm sorry two days here christmas
eve and uh uh thanksgiving that was it
that's the life just to make dinner and
then they kicked them off oh for real
was that was that in dc yeah it's called
a burning tree country club old school a
little bit of cash oh yeah i mean it
doesn't sound too new school
burning tree
not the most progressive bunch of boys
so this was so silver springs sounds
nice a little upper middle class
i wouldn't say upper i would say middle
i would say middle class did your
parents belong to that uh country club
no no no that country club was like for
like alan greensboro whatever [ __ ] his
name is i don't think that's a great
thing
the guy that's the guy down in north
carolina
alan greensboro's race car driver
sponsored by winston number 28
nascar last year
all right yeah so uh brother sisters so
i have one older sister one younger
brother how old what's the age
difference egypt my uh so it's my
younger brother is technically my half
brother okay yeah my mom got had two
she's getting messy
i got half brother technically is what
drops you in the trash too yeah yeah
cause there is no technically he is why
you but you know the difference right
like because i think if you i think if
you uh because it was i like was born
like raised with this dude like in my
head i'm like that's my brother all
right you know what i mean are you are
you guys still close super close like i
said i mean i call him my brother that's
why i say technically
um but yeah i mean he's like
my [ __ ] my brother you and your
sister say mom same dad same mom same
thing how older is how much older is you
my sister's two years older than me and
my brother's 10 years younger than me so
like oh that's exactly what i have
you're a child of divorce your parents
got divorced oh yeah yeah yeah divorced
when i was six months whoa [ __ ]
to me it's funny man whoa six might even
stick around to meet you that's what i'm
saying it's funny to like look at
someone that i like to look at this kid
i'm out of here
it's it's funny just in my head to like
look at a six month old kid and be like
i'm gonna bounce
just don't do it for me
they said i was gonna love them no
matter what but i don't did your dad
stay around like was he in the area so
my dad stayed in the area for like maybe
three four years okay virginia and then
he moved to
texas wow yeah you still are you close
with him i'm i'm close with him now
right um would you go to texas and stuff
to see him no
he would come like
he would come um like periodically did
he start a new family
uh no he did not never did he got a dude
he got engaged like i'm not [ __ ] you
like four times oh man this guy's got
issues yeah yeah oh he wanted out oh
yeah yeah yeah he wanted to be free oh
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] motorcycle
tearing out out of the cul-de-sac oh
yeah
you just standing there with the
basketball pouncers yeah we're six
months old
yikes he left before your first step so
you couldn't follow him yeah
damn it i gotta get out of here before
this tale starts
i gotta [ __ ] shake this kid
he's gonna be all over me so how quick
did your mom get remarried uh
i was 10. you were 10. so for a while it
was just you your sister me and my
sister my mom and what did your mom do
she's a nurse
a hospice nurse okay so caring all that
baggage
but she does well she was able to
support you guys i mean in the beginning
it was it was tough it was nice yeah i
don't know what you heard about hospice
nursing because oh she does well i
thought
nurses do well yeah but that's that's a
one income factor his dad walked on him
in six months i'm trying to help the cat
out jesus christ
holy [ __ ]
never have you work at the santa claus
shop
yeah well he's like no it was he's like
money was tight that's what i'm getting
at
yeah money was uh money was was a bit
tight for a few years she figured it out
where did you guys live during this time
were you in an apartment or a house a
house okay so so the the cul-de-sac
house that was my technically second
house when i was like one to ten
i lived in just a again very similar
neighborhood different house on like a
busy street um
yeah and she was the [ __ ] money was
tight we'd like split got she was able
to break the house is what i'm saying
that's pretty good
yeah i mean you know i think my dad and
my mom bought it together and my dad
bounced and so he left and didn't like
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah this is getting
[ __ ] sad this is what it is
oh okay
within the first six minutes your dad
friends of texas
we're in
this is the show
all right so
you're 10 years old your mom starts
there you're nine eight years old yeah
yeah your mom starts dating this new guy
he starts coming around yeah he starts
coming in too really yeah she got prego
fastest and how are you about that one
he started showing up didn't even know i
didn't even know i i like i was so
preoccupied i was like i'm i'm an
athlete i was so preoccupied with like
getting good at sports okay that another
person i didn't and he was one of those
dudes that like wasn't uh like his
energy wasn't like dominating the room
he was just one of those dudes
like a prius this [ __ ] would
just
just
just
that's a perfect way to describe
somebody he's just got prius vibes dude
i don't know what to tell you yeah he
was there but you know whatever
nice doesn't take up a lot of space good
gas mileage
yeah and are they still together now
they're not okay oh jesus christ yeah
[ __ ] jerry springer i like it yeah so
yeah so my brother was born literally
like well they married at this time they
were married but it was more like oh
you're pregnant
let's i do really type of thing yeah she
was pregnant on like walking down the
aisle damn and i was you i didn't did
you go to the wedding yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah were you in the wedding i
here's the funny thing don't remember
yeah i probably blocked it out i don't
remember for sure for sure
being in a parent's wedding
buddy i was it's a tough one how how old
were you when you about to say oh they
got they had the k they had my younger
brother when i was 10.
i'm 10 years older than him and they
probably got married like two years
later so where was i guessing
his was in vegas
we were doing well that year a 10 year
old on a flight to las vegas
there was no layovers
you were in the wedding i was in the
wedding i don't remember what i don't
think i was like a ring bearer i don't
know what the [ __ ] i was i was cj
give it up for mikey on the ones and
twos you're over there working the prime
rib station that's how my stand-up
career started
um okay how was your sister in all this
uh she's a little bit older she's
probably more aware of what was popping
off i was just being like oh i'm wearing
a tuxedo i'm cool like i didn't know
what to [ __ ] change
yeah yeah yeah
um yeah i think she was definitely more
affected about the whole situation okay
again i do i don't remember like me
being
yeah i don't remember like at me looking
at the guy like you're not my dad i just
don't remember any of that i just
remember like okay i was like go with
the flow guy i was like yeah
where's my sega genesis did you did you
see your father periodically from the
six months to the to the 10 year old
yeah yeah yeah yeah you did he would pop
in every once in a while yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay yes what would you
guys do when he would pop in would he
take you to like yeah we'd go to foot
locker yeah he'd give me some shoes
we'd go to the [ __ ] amc yeah we'd
watch a movie
maybe casino who knows
that was the only one who took me out of
it i remember that really yeah yeah yeah
i mean that's i mean you guys know it
was fine
oh yeah that's the type of guy we're
talking about so he just this guy's
awesome dude this guy's [ __ ] great
dude that's their seven-year-old the
casino that's a wayward dad that came
after goodfellas right so they had he
had to know what he was he just wanted
to see that yeah that's all that was but
yeah but that's the type of dude that's
awesome he was like i want to see it i
got kids i wanna i guess i'll bring him
but that's the only movie that's great
only movie he ever took me i remember
that he like there's scenes i gotta
forget exactly what scenes but he would
like close my eyes and eventually he's
like i can't [ __ ] yeah this is yeah
maybe sharon stone was sucking joe
dick yeah that might have been it god
she was so hot in that movie it was holy
cool [ __ ] yeah
oh god damn but yeah that was that was
the sort of like the the it's just every
every other weekend it was just that it
was like foot locker something and and
and a movie and we'd stay at a marriott
that's pretty good yeah whoa whoa wait a
minute
all right he would he would come into
town and stay in the marriott and you
would go stay at the hotel with him yeah
yeah and you're in silver springs um
yeah i like that no no i think that's
okay yeah you're spending time with your
dad you know yeah yeah guess
that's all right but it wasn't i'm sure
it was like a marriott conference center
it it was my my dad and my dad had as
money
he was always responsible financially
with you guys um yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what kind of
gas should we talking about here what
line of work are we looking at he worked
in technology so he was like yeah yeah
yeah that's pretty good really
especially in the 90s they did all right
that's what i'm saying really you guys
remember next town yeah what about a
jerk off i don't know so many people
don't remember the chirp church shorty
that was your dad
what was my dad your dad was john nextel
holy [ __ ] how are you doing in marriott
um no he was uh
he was a vice president of next hell
then he moved on to wow holy [ __ ] so we
are talking a little bit of chaos a
little bit of cash
i mean i would say i would say in the
grand scheme of cash a little bit of
cash we're not we're not talking about
like bentley in a driveway sure yeah you
know we're talking about it's okay i'm
doing well pull up in a lexus yada yada
yada yada stadium up on the next tell
where you at yeah oh
he never gets back to you
ever
but what not a minutes kids one call the
next
now that's awesome though yeah so you
see him spread you see him throughout
then when your mom got remarried you
just still see him but he still i would
you guys had your same routine yeah same
same [ __ ] routine same two i think
what happened was is when things started
getting uh the the routine stopped after
i got a license and then things started
getting like he's like hey i'm gonna be
in town i'm like well sick i'm gonna be
at a party i don't want to like sure i
got enough shoes i already can't see
casino i don't yeah what are we what do
we do what are we doing here yeah you're
going to tgi fridays i don't know
yeah that's that totally makes that
makes sense yeah hey you weren't there
when i was you know when i was a kid
what's also you just become it's like
not a priority anymore you're like yeah
dude we just you know i know what we do
when we get together and it's fun but
like i'd rather get black out drunk and
try my friend yeah you know he'll go
with a couple trying to score with some
chicks yeah i'm trying to finger girls
with chris gillis the jew
that's a real name
that is a real name
trying to finger prop bond broads with
the boys yeah yeah what was the sports
situation what what did you play uh
mostly basketball but it was mostly
basketball
serious about basketball [ __ ] high
school basketball silver springs yeah
yeah yeah name of the high school good
council high school our lady of good
counsel wwcac
conference with the math and gonzaga
your boy was a hooper dude is that a
catholic school it is are you catholic
uh
yes
your your dad's last name my dad is
jewish my mom is catholic i went to a
catholic school my whole life nice um
but honestly culturally i feel
i feel like inside i feel jewish yeah
yeah well you immigration i always
assumed you were by the name and your
demeanor
your [ __ ] crooked nose
i did not say that i
did that's terrible i'm married to a
jewish woman by the way hey um
don't come don't don't cancel me
so
you're focused on basketball catholic
school were you were you christened and
confirmed i was i was christened later
in life because i was born jewish so
what age
oh god i think i was
christened when i was like i remember oh
that's not good i know
forever was it in a pool no no it was
hilarious no it was in it was a babbling
brook no it was in like a a bird bath
what what the [ __ ] is that in the chat
in the regular thing
[Laughter]
my uncle was in mario it was weird
i got a nice sauna ho ho ho gentlemen
the holidays came early with the boys at
manscape the leading men's hygiene brand
um they just launched new products
including their all new ultra premium
body wash and two in one shampoo because
that's the trashiest shampoo you can get
who do i do one shampoo and one
conditioner two and one baby saves time
give yourself the gift or someone who
needs it
the gift of beautiful skin hair and
balls this holiday season go to
manscape.com use promo good for 20 off
plus free shipping
um guys the performance package 4.0 also
includes a cop crop preserver crop
reviver anti-chafing ball deodorant
moisturizer and toner get your boys
feeling right down there that's what
we're doing uh they also obviously have
the lawnmower 4.0
with the advanced skin safe technology
to reduce cuts on your nuts this time of
year as you know i was an old blade and
cream guy until this manscape came my
life changed the game you get 20 off in
free shipping with code garbage at
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com use promo code
garbage to clean up your nuts and make
santa proud this year do it let's talk
about all form baby uh if you've been
listening to the pod for a while you
know we're a big helix family over here
helix mattresses and helix has left the
bedroom and has started making sofas
it's the easiest way you can customize a
sofa using premium materials at a
fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you pick out the size the shape
the legs the color the fabric whatever
you want you can make it yours they got
arm chairs love seats sectionals the
whole nine yards they sent us one uh we
put it here tooties it's fantastic
it took i put it together by myself in
about 40 minutes not even maybe it all
snaps together screws in they give you
all the parts there's no hard
instructions to read it's easy peasy
they also have 100 days they give you
100 days to decide if you want to keep
it it's more than three months if you
don't love it they'll pick it up for
free and you'll get a free refund
um
all form is also does financing and
flexible payments so an amazing sofa is
never far away they also have a forever
warranty that is literally forever to
find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com garbage all form is offering
20 off all orders for our listeners
allform.com garbage one more time get a
pen get a paper all form.com garbage do
it okay yeah but i mean i i started
jewish i got the i got the brisk the old
the snip snip sure on your oil when you
were born you had the brisk yeah yeah
yeah yeah cause i was gonna be a joke
they were still but you got you know you
got ripped off on get ripped off on the
bar mitzvah no bomb it's for pissed
tough look pissed did you do communion i
did you know what what what's that cash
like it's average it stinks it's average
my jewish friends were [ __ ] dragged
up 30 40 50 60 g's yeah going to tahiti
when they're [ __ ] 14. dude
what was their bubby and their zeta
would give them all that was the
grandmother and grandfather would just
be like oh yeah my zeta gave me 20 grand
i'm like what yeah i got 200 bucks in a
[ __ ] vfw meatball [ __ ] platter
[ __ ] [ __ ] i can't put a price on
love though
you want to be with the tribe okay yeah
sister go to catholic school too sister
went to the same high school
same high school private school big
sports family we're all just [ __ ]
hooping every goddamn day how long did
your mom stay with uh husband number two
uh about a year
what
about a year like a revolving door down
there in silver springs you're talking
about my mom
your mom gets pregnant she meets this
guy they get married you move into the
cul-de-sac house your brother is born
yeah where does that guy go that guy
goes to texas too no she's not no i'm
not joking i'm talking started working
for my dad i started working for sprint
this guy this guy
my mom works for orbits
okay oh he's got them cell phones
[Laughter]
yeah uh i refused to have an iphone
uh what the [ __ ] was he saying
yeah it was great
uh where did he go
oh uh he's he just yeah they just they
got they were separated for a little bit
he just he he went back to his old house
it was it was a kind of a weird
smorgasburg of a smart smorgasbord for
[ __ ] life yeah because literally he
the stepdad came with three kids wow
what and and they were all older so like
i had this how much older
like significantly like like five six
years living in the house though yeah so
when you got this cul-de-sac house yeah
those three dudes [ __ ] three
dudes in the house just like moved in
it was so weird because for like for
that let's notice how he said dudes and
not kids oh that's a tough one oh
straight up dude there's just dude
if he's 10 and they're 16. they might as
well be 30. that's what i'm saying dude
i remember this this dude his name was
rob i don't know i need to say his name
but [ __ ] it he he i would literally
you know when you're young and you think
things are cool and then retrospectively
this is not cool at all yeah most of my
life yeah
this had a bowl cut for a long time
he used to wear lee pipes what do you
want from me bloustein this uh this dude
had reese's peanut butter cups i'm
always listening yeah
this guy sounds pretty cool if you ask
me and sour cream on your pringles and
for some reason i i thought that was so
cool i would go down there every single
day and steal like what but he had like
a lot like one of those like big packets
of reese's now every day i'll just go
steal one and like five to six pringles
i remember counting because i'm like oh
he's not going to know five players this
is one of your step brothers yeah
yeah yeah
yeah what are you what are you where
would he keep them in the down like in
the pantry or in his room no in his room
under his roof yeah and he was the first
person to introduce me to rap i didn't
know anything about rap i was like oh
elvis presley's sick and then he came
along and introduced me to rap really
kind of chasing the elvis presley my mom
my mom loves child though my mom loved
elvis and and
literally elvis and the beatles that's
all i listened to as a kid i didn't i
didn't know anything and then he came in
he was like hey man how about tupac and
i was like huh and then he just and then
i just really [ __ ] changed my life
damn yeah talking about taking a step
there going from jailhouse rock to
[ __ ] dupont
picking it up
there wasn't a situation in the house
though where
um because i could see that i would feel
bad
with all these different people moving
in you're not that close to them there
wasn't like uh this is his food this is
their food this is your food there
wasn't [ __ ] like that nah there was
there wasn't [ __ ] like that there was no
like political beef in the house yeah it
was just i think and also like the
family was only together for like i mean
so so those kids left with the dad so
this weird if they hung around
just kidding later pops i'm hanging here
i got the cul-de-sac they might want to
trade up
so one of them all three of them moved
in two of them moved out like within
like a couple months of and then they
moved in with their mom so the oldest
one stayed in the basement so it was me
my sister
the newborn and the oldest and then my
new dad and my mom what was the oldest
how old was the oldest he was probably
15 16. but in my head when you're that
young oh he's 48. you got some dude
living in the basement like he has a
beard yeah
might as well be like an uncle or
something yeah
oh man that's trash
where was grandma grandpa anybody like
that your mom's so my mom's my mom's mom
and dad did at that okay and then my my
grandfather dead on my dad's side the
only one that was like alive and still
is is my grandmother your dad
my dad and she lives my whole dad's out
of family either lives in well they're
all like born in brooklyn and they all
moved to like uh uh cherry hill new
jersey so you didn't see her by us yeah
yeah yeah yeah so you didn't see her
that much i didn't see that much it was
basically it was the the [ __ ] the
blaustein brunch that was it that was
the family that was the family
but essentially because when you meet
people when you're that young they have
this weird like heavy impacts i remember
going to school and my teachers being
like oh you have an older brother they
could just like [ __ ] tell because
you're not
it's either like you're like this kind
of like innocent not knowing anything
person or you like have like weird
confidence when you have older because
you have to like live through like war
when you're growing up yeah you've
learned yeah you've learned
pringle's confidence walking around the
school hey that's a big dick energy
right there dude he found he found that
they were missing and like was
this dude was a lunatic he burned a car
to the ground he was [ __ ] like yeah
he went to jail for a little bit
oh hey it's a family show
back this up a little bit let's hear
about the arson come on yeah i mean
there was a he was like you know one of
those like 16 year olds that had a he
was just all angry and anxious blah blah
blah and there was one night where he
was just he left the house and he came
back super late and there was a car in
like a nicer neighborhood that was just
literally lit to [ __ ]
lit on fire and everyone was like oh let
me guess and then all around the car
there was pringles and
i was like let me guess who did it
it was the point they wouldn't figure it
out if it wasn't for these
whatchamacallits laying around anyway
damn dude and you skipped all that you
don't really have any of that aggression
or anything like oh no i might i have
anger issues
was that more geared towards the new dad
not the ultimate you're not your dad it
wasn't geared towards it it wasn't
geared towards literally anybody i just
have like this weird like i don't know i
think as dudes we all kind of have like
a hairpin trigger and like sure a little
bit of rage so when they when they moved
out your mom kept the house in the
cul-de-sac and that's just you your
sister my little brother brother yeah
and then yeah and then my mom that was
it and it felt a little you know less
stuffy pretty you know pretty normal and
then that's when
you know
it's about what i don't even grade i was
in whatever like seventh or eighth grade
and then you started becoming aware of
things and then high school and then
it's just like oh this is just my life
sure your mom stayed single from yeah
from earlier it was the last one that
was the last thing that was the last one
you have boyfriend now no no she hasn't
dated since that guy just doesn't really
i mean yeah you're striking out 150
times
eventually you're like i'm not good at
baseball
[Laughter]
still a nurse still working still dude
hospital service for 35 years
doug that'll like that's who it is it is
a it's it's a weird
like this really like warped sense of
like
reality because everything everyone you
talk to is like an almost ghost sure you
know what i mean everybody yeah they're
all about to die so it's like there's
weird like she has this thing where
she'll like
she like i don't even know how to
describe it bro she like likes she i
think she lives in so much sadness that
she almost like likes to like make a
situation sad let me let me explain
cause that sounds horrendous like she'll
literally how do i describe it like if a
waiter comes over and
like can i take her or whatever and
it'll leave and she'll literally kind of
make up a backstory about the waiter to
like have empathy towards the waiter
because i think she's just more
comfortable in like
in like she needs to give empathy i know
exactly what you're talking about do you
know that's crazy yeah i like it okay
i'm glad i don't know if i'm articulate
about my story
but like sure it's like projection yes
yeah because she like she
is she's more comfortable when there's
like something [ __ ] happening sure
that's the world she operates in all
right exactly yeah so she'll literally
be like oh he looks sad like i you know
i hope he's he probably broke up with
his girlfriend like he had a tough
something yeah exactly you're trying to
enjoy yourself with the mozzarella
sticks and the shirley tea yeah like mom
loosen it up a little bit it's the
fuddruckers a lot of moms kind of dude
that rockers i love a good face as they
do get older like sometimes i'll be
talking to my mom and it's like my did
you hear about you know janine's nephew
he got shot in the head and then you
hear about this guy he pissed him i'm
like i feel like this is horrible do you
remember jerry lived down the street
from us like 30 years cancer yeah
what's [ __ ] up about that is i'm sure
your parents do it to you my mama walked
me down a whole journey oh do you
remember blah blah blah she was the blah
blah blah blah and then eventually i
catch on and we're talking about four or
five minutes down the road and like oh
she got hit by a truck yeah wait just i
don't need i don't i don't know that
right start getting warm and fuzzy
reminiscent exactly oh dude she's the
best oh the cute girl that used to be
the thing yeah murdered today what the
[ __ ] helicopter blade took a head right
off diesel it was in the mall worlds get
real dark as they get older what is that
yeah i don't know man i think they're
they're coming they're probably
wrestling with their mortality or
something yeah and everybody they got
time on their hands too yeah so they're
all sitting around just chirping yeah
now my dad's on tick tock now
all he was talking about is [ __ ]
never stops dancing
really good at leaving also really good
at the renegade yeah check out his floss
all right so then you go off to college
go off to college would you go to school
uh coastal carolina university
sounds like a landscaping company it's
pretty close it's pretty close i
literally i went for uh i went for the
pgm program which is uh professional
golf management i have i know a lot of i
have buddies wait you want to shout out
you wanted to manage a professional
golfer uh well it's not it's not really
that it's literally like uh do you know
like it to be like a head pro at a
country yeah it's a golf course of
course he's like yeah golf okay you have
to like learn the grass did you play
golf in high school i did i play golf in
high school like i went from basketball
and i was like oh i'm 5'8 i'm not gonna
do this and i got super into golf
and then i and then i kind of quit
basketball my junior or my senior year
sorry i quit basketball and i just
really just leaned into golf and then i
was like oh this is what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna be i'll be a head pro and i'll
like you know own a percentage of the of
the golf shop and shortly and i'll have
a family play on the team at school i
did yeah
yeah oh no no not college my the golf
team at coastal was [ __ ] stupid good
oh really yeah everybody goes down there
for that so how are you going to be a
pro if you couldn't even make the team
in college
yeah
so a professional like it's just to be a
head professional at a country club
those dudes aren't like pga oh really i
thought you had to be no no it's just
like you're a good golfer yeah you have
you have to be good you have to like
pass what the [ __ ] it called it
doesn't matter what it's called but like
you have to have like uh you have to you
have to have a certain handicap yeah you
have to have like a four or five
handicap to like to be accepted and then
you have to like to do the books
nice yeah i mean it gets boring and [ __ ]
dude i literally quit my like sophomore
year i was looking around and i was
these are [ __ ]
cucks
who are these people yeah and i was just
i can't i can't do it so i just i just
moved like into management and i just i
just started like just doing regular
business [ __ ] what were the grades in
high school like
they were fine cheap or uh s.a.t score
they're fun
everything's fine it was fun it was like
number one
i think isis is what we're here for good
i think i think it was like probably
like a 3.0 i would say gpa not bad and
then yeah
the sats
12.
12 is good any scholarships at coastal
or anything no nothing no nothing
nothing nothing i got a question how
many schools did you apply to one oh wow
that's either really confident or really
trashy
i was i dude
i was i was just confident i just knew
what school i wanted to go to because
two of my other friends from high school
were going for for a golf management two
and i was like [ __ ] it before and we did
all applied to the early decision and
then we all got in and i was like cool
i'm done my sister applied to like 19
schools yeah that's also very tragic
it's got to be like three or four
you can't go both ends of the spectrum
it's wild i got shot down by everybody
really oh man where'd you go where'd you
go i ended up going to widener
university it's never going you said i
ended up going why there's not bad right
no it's a great it's good school i like
when did you graduate again never yeah
i dropped out my sophomore year why what
happened i went down to cocaine uh a
little bit of that um was our mascot
actually uh
no i went to theater school oh yeah but
that's not a linear transaction and you
know that too am i at trial here
i don't try to church it up i mean come
on what do you do put the screws in next
tell over here let's go
i was i was i was gonna have to take an
extensive
summer program to get myself back into
school
what were you doing why why'd you fall
off just because you went to like you
followed pearl jam on tour or something
didn't you
you went to you went to like nirvana's
house you did something weird that was a
spring break that's all no my football
career was obviously winding down when i
in my sophomore year i realized the
freshmen that were coming it could sound
so prestigious it was winding down you
play your drug out if you play d3 in
jersey
what are you talking about if i gotta be
honest i got tired of breaking records
you know michael you scored so many
touchdowns
you gotta leave a little bit
dude you were high for most of the 90s
what are you talking about
don't [ __ ] try to church this up here
i wasn't going to put the work in to uh
excel got it on this team i also played
the cross i i walked on that that was
wasn't gonna happen because they brought
in really really good players my
sophomore year so you were like an
athlete athlete huh a little bit a
little bit but like kevin said there was
there was a narcotic issue
uh we had a good time we party we were
in a frat we had fun and it was just i
was going nowhere i was an english major
then i had to do hotel restaurant
management so i wouldn't get kicked off
the football team yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so it was just what friends were
you know i was on a frat too theta kai
shut up hey that was a pike okay yeah
yeah yeah well i'll get these two guys
up right now what should we do you guys
weren't in france
no losers yeah you guys are [ __ ] lit
penises on their forehead and get out of
here yeah me and kibby didn't have to
pay for friends
homeschooled
no i just didn't go to middle school
it's different butcher box butcher box
butcher box baby we're talking butcher
box when it comes to the meat that will
be the centerpiece of your holiday meals
your family get togethers your company
parties whatever quality matters and
when you invest in high quality meat
from butcher box the benefits go way
beyond a great tasting meal butcher box
horses all their meat from partners with
the highest standards for quality no
more searching the grocery store um for
100 grass-fed beef free-range organic
chicken chicken wild called seafood it
all comes directly to your door they
sent us a box i mean it's got to be
about it seems like 32 tons of meat it's
coming out of my ears over here we're
making fresh we're making meatballs
we're doing steaks i got chicken whole
chicken's going it's fantastic there's
no antibiotics or hormones each box
contains 8 to 14 pounds of meat
depending on the box you choose that's
enough for 24 individual meals what are
we doing here get on board you can also
do a custom box or use one of those
either way you get exactly what you want
butcher boxes offering new members 20
off and free bacon in your first box
this offer is ending
uh soon so get this deal before it's
gone sign up at butcherbox.com ayg
that's butcherbox.com ayg to get free
bacon and 20 off your first box do it
let's talk about ladder baby if this
pandemic has shown us one thing and so
your life can turn upside down at the
drop of a dime
which makes sense why a lot of people
are getting life insurance especially
term life coverage which is surprisingly
affordable why not pay a little bit each
month to protect the ones that you love
if you're asking yourself these
questions choose ladder ladder is 100
digital no doctors no needles no
paperwork when you apply for 3 million
in coverage or less you just need a few
minutes a phone a laptop to apply ladder
smart algorithms work in real time so
you'll find out if you're instantly
approved or not
if you prefer to talk to a person a team
of license agents doesn't work on
commissions so they'll be able they're
not they'll help you and not upsell you
there's no hidden fees canceled at any
time get a full refund the whole nine
yards
latter policies are issued by issuers
with long proven histories of paying
claims finally since life insurance
costs more as you age now is the time to
cross it off your list so go to
ladderlife.com garbage today to see if
you're instantly approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage ladderlife.com garbage now back
to the show
family high school i wasn't against rats
but i went to temple which was in the
city the school it depends on this so
it's like
we're in philadelphia so you're like it
just didn't make sense our school was
very small it was very it was like it
was almost like a fifth year of high
school very small very dominated by the
sports teams and by the by the uh by the
frat life yeah yeah so but it was great
but yeah it wasn't linear from college
to theater school no but it worked it
was a summer at digging dishes and
soul-searching
and i ain't had no cul-de-sac to fall
back on either
[Laughter]
anyway back to you
give it to me i made my mistakes
all right well let's get a little are
you garbage here sure let's find out
um let's go back
um to the cul-de-sac house
because those were your prime years what
was the uh the christmas situation what
were the decorations what was the tree
so my mom loved a good christmas okay
oh she i mean we're talking about early
decorating i mean we're talking about
maybe three weeks four weeks before it's
pretty good right after thanksgiving
probably yeah yeah she loves she loved
going to the getting a good tree of
douglas fur oh
douglas first are a little bit of cats
all right now we're talking yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
she knows how to strike out with dudes
but she's really good
i'll tell you what dude
um yeah little was your dad's probably
left before christmas yeah
he would have stayed around for a little
bit
white lights colored lights
white lights classy yeah colored lights
on douglas ferns
white lights
uh she she still to this day does the
santa claus thing still to this day what
do you mean she'll like rap she'll like
ask for a christmas list she'll put you
know she'll wrap the presents super nice
she'll literally put like two michael
from santa in this like kind of
calligraphy like santa writing to this
day dude it's fun it's in the spirit but
there will also be presents for mom
so what we would do is christmas eve we
do like the family thing we do like that
hey mom this is my gift from bubba buddy
we gotta take this slow here okay all
right so christmas eve christmas eve you
do the family thing we do the family
exchange you give the presents that on
the card say from michael from mom from
sister yep yep yep and then christmas
morning and christmas morning we all
santa we all sleep upstairs and we all
sit on the we all sit on the steps and
my mom takes pictures when she's down
there and she goes okay you guys can
come down and we all run down and it's
the trees lit up douglas fir white
lights and there's a bunch of presents
underneath from santa in this kind of
cute calligraphy
and we and we go to town that's pretty
classy that's very cool because i have
said that the family that opens presents
on christmas eve is trash i agree oh
go ahead trash but the way your mom does
it
is classy can i add another classy thing
or maybe it's trash i don't know you
guys this is this is your show
we you know some families run down and
they all open the gifts yeah at the same
time it takes 15 minutes we go one at a
time one by one like oh
thank you you guys
one by one you mean you open the present
he opens the press not you open your
whole pile no no we go one by one so
when everyone's opening a present you
can you can sort of uh you're you're
involved in the opening it's like it's a
yes it's an event rather than just
[ __ ] terry oh it takes us it
literally takes us we have to do like an
intermission we have to do like a
breakfast intermission because it takes
so long what is that breakfast
um so every single year she makes i
don't know what i don't know what it's
called it's like an egg uh and like an
egg loaf
yeah dude
i don't know
i didn't have a dad an egg loaf
quiche so we got quiche we have
calligraphy we have white lights that's
all home runs
home run did you guys also do hanukkah
uh no my dad was a big write a check put
it in a card guy gotcha um yeah he's my
kind of guy and at that point at a
certain age that's really that's all
that matters that's got the fun of
opening the presents then you know you
got a little bit of [ __ ] steel to
roll around the new year with yeah a
little bit of ghee a little bit of
butter
cash
gas nice
christmas sounds nice what's the
decorations outside it's not like santa
claus plastic on the lawn or anything no
so the only christmas decorations that
happen in our house is uh outside is we
have these like kind of nice hedges and
she throws some white lights very classy
classy lady oh she's a very classy lady
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah very artsy i'm
assuming we never ate out for
thanksgiving thanksgiving's always at
the house thanksgivings at the house
to the nines [ __ ] everything you can
think of a very family event is it just
the fouriers usually so uh i would say
probably half the time it's the four of
us and it has to help me go to my aunt's
house and same thing just okay massive
thanksgiving everyone's everyone's
cooking everyone's having a great time
that's pretty good yeah it's good but
yeah it's it's a very like holidays are
massive enough it's not like oh i'm
gonna go i'm gonna go to timmy's for
thanksgiving no you're not yeah like you
don't even ask sure
if you ever go to a friend's for
thanksgiving he never made sense
it is a eye-opener if like you go over
there maybe like in high school or grade
school when you first start becoming
friends with somebody you do your dinner
and then you go over there man if it's
awesome it's awesome if it's bad you're
like come get me dude there was one
thanksgiving that my my other aunt from
britain cooked
it was
[ __ ] horri hor
everyone was like what drool michael
there's like olives [ __ ] huh yeah
hollow i don't want i do i don't even
know it's just it was just everything
was [ __ ] rocks with that dude take
that commie [ __ ] back i
you and the redcoats can kick [ __ ]
rocks
this is america god damn it finally some
cranberry sauce in the next couple of
minutes i start slitting throats
[Laughter]
[ __ ] back to scotland
partying over here
um
very good
what was the name of the grocery store
growing up
snyder's hmm how was that was that nice
if you had to gauge it now um it is fine
it's angry
uh yeah it's a very um
it's how do i describe it's very like um
kind of like it has like a community
feel it's not like a big conglomerate
okay it's like uh it's like a neighbor
neighborhood that's what i want to say
it's like a neighborhood neighborhood
grocery and i remember uh the the people
that worked there the goddamn cashiers
and the bagger that was like a dream of
mine yeah i was like oh i can't wait to
be able to have a guy
i mean dude they were like gods to me i
remember i was a bagger and a cashier
you lucky [ __ ] you guys actually what
are we talking about [ __ ] at all
your dad were for next tell no
no he didn't no but i also don't talk to
him
a couple of peas in a bottle
jesus silver springs me
silver
all right that's good that's good that's
beautiful you live near a quarry
by any chance or did you ever play in a
quarry
somebody always died around there oh
yeah can't be doing that did i ever let
this what i've never heard the word
quarry in my whole life i just said egg
loaf too that's true that's true i don't
know words guys there's like two or
three quarries around my neighborhood
i'm gonna be honest
here's the thing maybe i don't even know
what you would no you would know if
you're a quarry kid yeah there's a
quarry
we had like we had uh like creeks like
pretty good greeks normal yeah
right there jumped to create my first
girl at a creek
sounds like a classy lady oh yeah i mean
dude we were like eleven
eleven yeah i do i was i was indeed a
smooth talker silver springs they moved
quick down there oh dude you know i was
i was yeah things were early for me in
that room were you one of those kids
that could hang like a poster of a girl
in a bikini on his wall no okay i would
get it no
what posters were hanging in in young
michael's room didn't have posters
really didn't have posters didn't have a
dad it was crazy
framed artwork on the walls uh i had a
jersey framed who's cool it was mine i
didn't do it though i didn't do it my
mom did it as like a gift that's nice
look right behind us hanging right there
that's that's looks like a sad jersey
you can still see the coke residue on it
it's spotlessly clean too
never worn in the game once
okay that's fine yeah that's you're that
your mom's a [ __ ] classy lady she's
totally normal yeah she's super the only
little like odd things that are hanging
is like uh you know like homecoming
memorabilia and [ __ ] like [ __ ] yeah okay
i mean yeah i had like you know like
collages of like sure of course you know
2007 m3s on my [ __ ] all my little
collage best friends you know me weren't
you
just all the
teenager [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah of course
yeah was uh was burning leaves a
practice at the bloustein house
no
no burning leaves we we use regular bags
and we rolled them and we put them in
and uh it was the worst experience of my
life hated that was there a landscaper
in the picture oh no i was the landscape
really you cut your grass oh yeah here's
the thing
or a tractor
all right had to and then the little it
wouldn't start sometimes you had to like
press the little [ __ ] primer
baby you got to prime it my dad would
prime in that prime minute and choking
it and running it yeah the choke was
real big oh it's always tough when
you're like a seven-year-old that knows
what a choke on an engineer well dude i
like my mom had to like hold it and i
was the one pulling it out
because she couldn't do both
yeah yeah yeah yeah but i literally was
like they looked at me as if i was like
the dead you know i mean so all that
[ __ ] all the electrical shorts all like
the landscaping all to take out the
trash all that [ __ ] with your wire
man
yeah [ __ ] pain tuition it was
awful uh ever race remote control cars
professionally professionally
professionally
um
no did you have a remote control car
growing up no oh no i had one i had one
gas powered
no electric it's like a regular one okay
it wasn't like a sports mod one it was
no it wasn't one of those but it was
like a real cool one those kids [ __ ]
those kids yeah [ __ ] those kids it was a
it was one that like uh had like tank
wheels does that make sense
it was like there was two or i'm sorry
one and then like it was like in a
triangle so you're radios
yeah yeah that's good yeah that was that
was the only one i ever i ever had
didn't i honestly didn't love it when it
ran into batteries i think i just
[ __ ] yeah i wasn't big on either i
remember my buddy the one time got the
one you could drive into the wall and it
would like flip over remember that one i
had like the two different kind of
wheels on it i loved the commercial that
was cool for like 20 minutes
let's wrap this up well dude i love this
i love smoke sticks
i love the commercials more than i love
the actual [ __ ] the commercials for toys
you didn't realize accessories not
included yeah you didn't realize that
they had it set up perfectly they had a
fake little mountain that you were over
top of and gi joe was coming out you're
trying to do that [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
on your couch yeah like a boxing your
mom's pumps
i'm trying to make that a [ __ ] base
making a cardboard box cobra base play
stunk
yeah i mean i said i was like an only
kid for so long i played with myself my
sister never really want to play [ __ ]
g.i yeah yeah two years older sister
yeah oh yeah making the barbies [ __ ] you
know just normal stuff what was the of
course what was the bloustein family
vacations like we went to so for like
half of my life we went to ocean city
maryland my my grandmother no good
it's fun but it's trashy yeah it's very
trashy i didn't know it's trash go
kart's a mini golf oh yeah yeah and just
yeah caterpillar with the [ __ ]
convertible thing that goes over it when
it's going around i hated that thing
what are you talking about yeah there
once i was like let's go i wanted a
little ride
to ride it's like um one of the ones
that goes around like that and it's a
caterpillar and at a certain point the
cover goes on it oh i know what you mean
yeah it's like the it's just like the
circle one yeah
you guys ever [ __ ] with the zipper
no yes oh man that ride was the best
dude it was like it was uh like four
individual carts
and i know you're talking yeah and it
was like i don't dude it's so hard to
explain this i got it right here yeah
yeah you're flipping like five different
ways [ __ ] yeah dad will [ __ ] blow
your hair back down i'll give you a cte
in that dream
i jumped in with the salt and pepper
shakers
um yeah so that was that was the ride
right there baby that was that was 100
the ride um but yeah my grandma my
grandma had uh like a beach house condo
thing all right nice yeah yeah yeah we
would just go there and then that was
half of my life my other other half mile
that's in maryland
in maryland ocean city maryland for
other half of my life we'd go to uh
outer banks north carolina that's pretty
good that was always like what rich
people did in my life outer banks very
classy yeah any disneyland disney world
trips no never never liked this kid i
like this kid never never never you got
did you guys go to disney world
disneyland yeah whoa that's our next
patreon goal actually really to whatever
2 800. this is not trashy we are my mom
went when she was my mom went after
uh we had graduated college she went
with a bunch of her girlfriends wow yeah
we never won if you go after 15 it's
over yeah like it's over you can't go
well there's like we've talked about it
a handful of times there's people now
like i started going because like now
that my mo we have a bunch of grandkids
my mom will take the grandkids that's
fine and then she's like oh like then
i'll end up going just because like
that's the family vacation sure um but
like i'll get on the i'll get on the
plane at like [ __ ] jfk or laguardia
oh my gosh and there's grown adults
sitting there with like mickey ears on
no kids dude mickey ears shirts 6 a.m
[ __ ] holding hands like two [ __ ]
real creepers disney adults yeah the
creepiest people disney adults dude they
have disney i don't know if you guys
talk they have disney gangs
it literally hangs
look it up they have disney gangs and
they like they represent like the
pluto's are fighting the mickeys i swear
to god that's literally it disney gang
it pops right up dude it's it's look at
this oh wow holy [ __ ] that is the
saddest thing i've ever seen in my life
wow i mean literally leather jackets
representing main street elite
disneyland i don't talk [ __ ] about them
they'll come [ __ ] those dudes look
pretty [ __ ] tough though i'll give
you that yeah they do it's real like
sons of anarchy
yeah they look like actual motorcycle
gang we take it all back you guys are
great people
no that's the saddest thing i've ever
seen that's really bad as an adult you
ever go to sandals or anything like that
hedonism
sandals sandals is a resort in like
jamaica there's you know there's oh
oh as an adult no or hedonism
are you just saying words to me hedonism
is like a [ __ ] resort oh oh ripping in
the tearing that's a real deep cut no
but my my dad did to he
oh dude my my relationship with my dad
is hilarious because it's like we my dad
started like talking to me like as i'm
like a friend like early really like all
these weeks
like
yeah eleven twelve but like literally he
talked about like butt play with me when
i was like 12. what yeah he was like you
know what you got to do you got a
million licking you gotta [ __ ] have
her look like he and i remember thinking
that okay guys wacky dude he literally
is he in the disney gang he should be
this dude
i never got the sex talk this is his sex
talk to me i was literally at his place
and he just you guys remember the adam
and eve catalogs starts banging a flight
attendant
do you guys remember the avenue
adam and eve adds yeah of course
it's like a little like a little catalog
thing yeah he literally walked in he
threw it like at my like i was like
playing with g.i joe's he i'm sh i [ __ ]
you know probably like 11 catalog and he
throws adam and eve catalog he just says
enjoy and just turns around no like
there was no i never got a sex talk
jesus christ did you guys get a sex dog
put an x next to whatever you like in
the catalogue okay my mom doesn't even
think i have sex
no i don't i don't know
waiting for my second marriage um
hmm have you ever had poison ivy as an
adult
no well what do you what do you what's
an adult after 18.
i used to get poison ivy all the time as
a kid sure
all the time dude my basketball court
was literally on a hill and every single
time i'd make it or miss it would go
down so make it or miss it so i'd just
be penalized regardless and i just run
down and get poison ivy literally every
[ __ ] month
what was the pet situation
this is gonna make me trash uh we had uh
we had a couple of
we had a cocker spaniel okay legit
but the grooming situation was cocker
spaniel because my mom was a single mom
like this didn't this dog didn't get
taken out it wasn't top of the priority
list man it was down in front of his
eyes it was down in front of its eyes
it was like
it was it was it was in like the like
like lived in the mud room
and like we would take it out something
it would dude 90s dogs are way different
and like everybody
there was a lot of 90s dogs that that's
how they lived yeah they were very
second-class citizens they were lucky to
be there yes and now it's like they have
top priority
what happened like literally i don't
understand the way that i treat my dog
is
like literally like a kid of course but
the way that dude that's exactly like
the 90s
dude it was just like he's got food he
goes out once a day that's what the
[ __ ] dog does we were still getting
society together back then we were still
trying to figure things out couldn't
start catering animals just yet
but what was we've we've i feel like
we've still corrected we over corrected
the ship but what was the pr shift well
i don't understand was it sarah
mclaughlin [ __ ] was that like lachlan
was that a could have been it because
that's kind of in and around when that
when that uh that the turn happened yeah
it could be i don't know i genuinely
don't know what happened because it was
like mildly accepted
to just be like yeah it's a dog lives in
the pool yeah he's like a
certain point like a garage dog
that's where he lives at a certain point
it was acceptable to take a dog
somewhere and leave it there and let it
run free and be wild or take a [ __ ]
duffel bag of puppies and and put it
somewhere a duffel bag who are you
hanging out with i have no idea god damn
dude there's one time i'm saying when i
was a kid that those are the things that
i worried about preferred uh hot dog
condiments
whoa all right so
when i was
younger it was no hold on i'm starting
to cut you off go ahead was that was
that it for the the pet situation that
was it yeah just one
rough 90s dog oh yeah yeah no rats no
snakes no mice no no no no hamsters very
good no no no no and eventually a
quote-unquote ran away and i still to
this day i'm like mom where's the dog
yeah where's the dog
there you go that's what they would do
back then that's all i was saying i
would never want to see puppies in a
duffel bag but it was a different time
back then people were crazy i don't even
know what you're talking about me
neither but i'm into it
uh hot dog go yes um someone was younger
ketchup just ketchup ketchup and uh
potato potato roll bun
yeah [ __ ]
gentleman yeah yeah yeah but now
i'm a mustard guy now i'm a ketchup i'm
a ketchup and mustard i was never and
mustard that's the only thing i put
mustard on i don't like mustard i don't
know i like mustard but i put it on my
hot dog a little bit of relish sometime
when i'm feeling frisky right what about
a pizza what are you getting on a pizza
i like a good everything supreme uh yes
that's what you call it everything
[Laughter]
are you more of a bagel bites or pizza
roll kind of guy
wow it says a lot about a man or lady oh
blue wow i'm gonna go
what would i prefer what i've had more
in my life but i wanted to do both
what did you get i think i would prefer
the
the uh i had more in my life the bagel
bites okay you're a bagel bites family
yep yeah
that's classier than pizza rolls though
i guess but i think i'd prefer pizza
rolls never got them
yeah chris gillis always had him
all those goddamn hand jobs
[Music]
name of your local pizza place growing
up
dominic's dominic's
pretty solid did you really pretty solid
yeah you're the merrell and me
uh
yeah what was the local chinese
restaurant in your hometown here's the
interesting thing
i don't know
i know where it is i know how to order
it i don't know what it's called there's
some chinese writing on top yeah it's
just a chinese restaurant typically a
lot okay
yeah yeah i mean yeah i there's i don't
yeah i think you're right dude i don't
think it has a name yeah if it's in like
a strip mall or whatever it's just like
whatever chinese restaurant it's just
like chinese food you want to take out
that's literally it um
yeah okay shoes yeah on or off in the
house
on wow
very much on
i i i don't i don't like a off house
it makes me upset as a guest as a guest
your shoes
especially if you're older if you're
like a kid i get take them off kids or
whatever running around and stuff but
like if i go over someone's house and
they ask me to take their shoes off it's
like what the [ __ ] are we doing i'll
i'll do it i'll do it but i'm not going
to like you sure of course that's the
last time i'm coming over after that so
yeah yeah it's like why don't you mop
yeah just mop like a normal person
because here's the thing you're going to
mop or sweep anyways yeah so just let's
just make it sooner yeah leave it until
you do it eventually yeah and [ __ ] your
carpet
it's weird when they put it on youtube
and it's like well we'd prefer but you
could do whatever you want yeah maybe
the [ __ ] walking around with your
shoes on
i don't like that i hate those
as a kid didn't have cable
not at all no didn't have cable bunny
ears what'd you do 20 years
what yeah dude my all through high
school too yeah there was no you didn't
have cable in high school nobody oh my
god we didn't we didn't get we got
internet crazy late
we got we didn't my mom just got cable i
swear to god like
five years ago wow that's [ __ ] you're
never coming back from that
holy [ __ ] yeah no cable no cable it was
really just like we had just a bit how
did you know what was going on we just
had just the networks we had like fox
nbc yeah cbs abc yeah and you know upn
and [ __ ] like that i know because
or the wb or whatever yeah you get the
upn yeah that's like practically amish
you didn't know what anybody was talking
about in high school you know what's
interesting man it's like i i
i
no one really was like nickelodeon like
i don't no one but mtv was probably big
mtv you're like my age yeah yeah mtv
sports center espn i never got any of
that oh my god yeah the other kids just
didn't want to hurt your feelings that's
true
they were like yeah i also saw regis and
kelly
it was great
good job michael masterpiece theater is
lit dude guys listen michael's coming to
the party don't mention that's so raven
very upset dude i was such a big like oh
yeah
guy for so much of my life oh that's so
rapid that's crazy dude i [ __ ] love
that thing i've never heard of that i'll
never watch it's awesome
who's this guy emerald legazzi
yeah dude sportscenter i literally
didn't watch sportsmen since i wasn't
looking until i was like in college
that's kooky
yeah that's kooky i only think i got one
or two more for you here oh yeah he's
chubby have you ever eaten at a strip
club and have you ever gone to a strip
club with a family member
um i have eaten at a strip club yikes
here's the thing though
we'll justify a little bit in college
uh
everything closed at two but strip clubs
were open this is coastal christian
carolina mountains academy yep uh
fighting school fighting roosters was
our [ __ ] oh my god
shanta clear to be precise
the fighting version the fighting is
[ __ ] terrible but the [ __ ] fights
yeah they would close the clubs but the
the strip clubs were open and they'd you
do byob at the strip clubs and they're
struggling without food so like so yes i
got a back door i get it yeah it's not
like college it's yeah
good
good they had great chicken fingers
it's [ __ ] awesome we got chicken
friggins fries everything they call them
titty fingers
try the chicken breasts what are we
doing here how's nobody gonna make that
joke come on
um what do you say go hold on have you
ever gone with a family member
no i'm not a big strip club guy okay i
hate it yeah you guys are strip clubs
guys no as a in early 20s sure but not
in
not in years i just always hated it
because it's like i'm not gonna [ __ ] you
guys the only time that it was great was
that was the first time you went i
remember the fantasy show bar in jersey
we went full nude two ladies shower
scene it was whoa
hot shower scene shower scene how was
that even i don't know i got a little
back room where they did a little show
holding a black box theater [ __ ]
it was like seeing mammoth for the first
time damn dude
real artistic
what do you got kip
uh
i mean i think we got him pretty [ __ ]
dead right you know what i mean i think
we could bring him the bailiff and put
the cuffs on you yeah put an orange
jumpsuit on you cause this kid's [ __ ]
garbage yeah you're trash man you're
trash oh you're trash oh yeah the no
cable
did no cable killed you
what was the mayonnaise in the house
what'd you use helmets or miracles
helmets okay that's not bad yeah
here's something i'm a miracle whip guy
what are you doing i just kept trying to
get you out
i tried to give you an outbreak i'm a
miracle with guy i'll [ __ ] shatter
from the roof how did that come from if
you didn't have it when you were a kid i
don't know something happened in college
and i had some disposable income and i
got a goddamn miracle and i was like oh
this is so much better you probably had
it at the strip club
it's got changed
it's
oh my god michael blaustein
buddy what do you got coming up you want
the folk started to know um i'm gonna
tour a bunch uh so just go on uh blough
comedy.combeela you comedy.com get the
tickets there um also uh stiff socks
podcast every wednesday uh with my
co-host trevor wallace
um and uh yeah dude that is that's
that's all i got the plug
uh guys uh cameron comedy on social
media come check out a live show coming
up albany syracuse hartford albany
syracuse hartford in the middle of
december it's gonna be the last shows of
the year and then 2022 we're coming out
swinging rocking and rolling
so i got
diced me there left me hanging
t-bone i closed out like i closed out
everyone all right guys we'll see you
next week
peace guys